we've got a voicemail number it's two
one nine two david p here's a voicemail
that came in somebody really doesn't
agree with I guess my identity I don't
know take a listen
yeah if you're just a surly young white
boy you got a lot of gall there I've
been keeping my eye on you
you're about as Hispanic as my phonebook
skin wallet is american-made right yeah
okay I mean I'm an immigrant from
Argentina I don't know what that makes
me but clearly this individual taking
issue with with my identity all right
sir well I'm glad that at least he has a
cushy enough situation where he can
spend his time worrying about the ethnic
identity of independent progressive show
hosts I don't know also Hispanic is not
a race in itself so I mean you can be
Hispanic and white Sonic and black and
that you know that that's what you are
right I'm of Hispanic culture you would
say anyway well I I don't listen this
guy's going to believe what he wants to
believe we're getting into the weeds on
the bonus show today a man gets life in
prison for raping and impregnating a
ten-year-old girl in Florida
a North Dakota bill would protect
drivers who accidentally hit and kill
protesters a year ago 62 people owned
the same amount of wealth as half the
world combined we have seen upward
concentration of wealth where now there
are eight people who owned the same
amount of wealth as the entire as half
of the world combined we will discuss
those stories and more on the bonus show
a few reminders number one the coffee is
coming very very soon
labels are done coffee is selected we
are doing some test prints of the labels
this week and then we will be off and
running it will be available on david
pakman.com we still have coupon code I
voted 17 available as a major discount
for david pakman show membership SIF the
normal rates at david pakman.com slash
membership are a bit high for you
then take the discount I voted 17 gives
you a huge huge discount and I encourage
you to use it and we are down to the
last few days of the David Pakman show
IndieGoGo campaign crowdfunding to
expand the reach of progressive media
david pakman.com slash donate that is
the one and only place where you can
donate to the campaign and donations
will stop being accepted it's sort of
poetic in a way at midnight Eastern Time
or maybe Pacific time listen the
timezone doesn't matter on the day of
Donald Trump's inauguration you will be
able to donate until the end of the day
on Donald Trump's inauguration Friday
January 20th david pakman.com slash
donate of course all members get instant
access to the bonus show and we will
speak to you then